[Music]
hi I'm Stephanie and today we're going
to look at how you can build a real-time
inventory management system using Google
Cloud spanner consumers are more
digitally connected than ever before
expectations for omni-channel shopping
experiences across online and offline
channels have increased experiences like
buy online pick up in store are expected
now rather than considered a convenience
for a company like Maxim oddish a
fictional retailer in-person shopping
has been the backbone of their retail
model for years as a premier retailer
they have hundreds of department stores
across the nation but to meet increasing
online demands they've had to undergo a
digital transformation in recent years
Maxim oddish customers have been
engaging with them through multiple
channels online through social media in
store and in-app naturally these
customers expect a seamless experience
across all of these channels to better
meet these expectations Maxim Adarsh
needed a complete picture of their
inventory flow and real-time
decision-making at scale this revealed
three key challenges they faced with
their technology stack one inconsistent
view of data across silos to cost
inefficiencies to management overhead
and seasonal scaling needs 3 an
inability to evolve with new business
needs this was a tough problem to solve
they were dealing with an extremely
large amount of data requiring them to
integrate event data from hundreds of
siloed data sources in a timely manner
these inventory events were coming in
rapidly and constantly changing
resulting in a lack of real-time
consistency across data sources for
example a woman's stress would show in
stock on the mobile shopping app but the
same dress showed out of stock in the
physical store
additionally running their existing
on-premise infrastructure led to
numerous cost inefficiencies to keep up
with the growing volume of data and meet
seasonal scaling during times like Black
Friday they had to increase their
on-prem data center for peak capacity
which aggravated operational costs and
tied up resources managing that
infrastructure last they were unable to
evolve with new business needs running
antiquated systems it was difficult to
adapt or modernize their applications
applying changes to monolithic systems
is a long arduous process this is where
Google Cloud helped turn things around
through their partnership Maxim oddish
was able to build an inventory ledger
solution with Google Cloud spinner at
its core this inventory ledger solution
is modeled based on retail environments
represented as a series of events these
events include things like items shipped
to a store item price updates or
customer purchase requests they chose
spanner to house their inventory event
ledger which would keep track of the
constant changes to inventory cloud
spanner is a managed database with
strong consistency in regional and
multi-regional setup no downtime and
scale insurance it combines the best of
relational semantics and scale in
addition spanner is a managed service
which frees maximum oddish from
operational overhead of their own
large-scale inventory systems whatever
an inventory event happens it's placed
in an append-only immutable event ledger
this guarantees inventory changes are
recorded in the system consistently
across multiple regions as customers buy
items across different channels in-store
or mobile spanner gives them a
consistent view of inventory no matter
what region or channel the shopper comes
from all replicas of the inventory
ledger are kept up to date in sync and
quickly available
what's more data houston spanner is
easily available to other Google cloud
services making it simple for Macs and
monitors to leverage capabilities like
bigquery for sequel based analytics
liquor for modeling and reporting and
auto ml and big for AML to apply machine
learning for smarter real-time
decision-making for example Maxim oddish
is able to integrate bigquery to create
this liquor dashboard they can conduct
further analysis using bigquery as a
managed data warehouse and
for interactive visualizations across
all stores by implementing this
inventory ledger solution with cloud
spanner Maximo nosh now has real-time
view of inventory across hundreds of
data sources and applications the
ability to scale up and down to support
peak traffic during large shopping
events managed services which
significantly decreases burdens of
operations and the ability to modernize
and adapt to new business needs through
an ecosystem of integrated cloud
services by leveraging just some of the
powerful features of Google Cloud Maximo
- is now able to do real-time decision
making for omni-channel retail and build
a seamless online and offline shopping
experience for thousands of happy
customers using a single source of truth
check out the link here to learn more
about spanner
[Music]